well we start today with a shift in the
balance of power potentially in the
Senate days after Herschel Walker
thankfully was defeated by the incumbent
Democratic senator from Georgia Raphael
Warnock and we said what great news it
won't be 50 50 in the Senate but it will
be 51.49 in favor of Democrats
Democratic but shaky Democrat let's call
her what she is shaky Democrat Kirsten
Cinema announces she is leaving the
Democratic party and becoming an
independent now I know I know I know
let's resist the urge to call this what
it may be at face value A desperate
attempt for attention from someone who
by virtue of the Democrats getting 51
rather than 50 seats immediately has a
diminished amount of power in the senate
in the sense that she alone cannot
prevent Democrats from getting a simple
majority let's actually sort of talk it
through and see what she had to say NPR
reporting here's what Cinema's switch
from Democrat to Independent could mean
for the Senate and the article uh
explains Cinema's move is unlikely to
change the Power Balance in the Senate
uh as it comes days after Senator
Raphael Warnock won the Georgia runoff
election to give Democrats a 51-49
majority that includes two Independents
who caucus with Democrats those are of
course Senators Bernie Sanders of
Vermont and Angus King of Maine Cinema
said she doesn't want to fit in a box
and the article goes on to talk about
the direction that the Senate could go
in and also talks about Arizona's 2024
Outlook as Kirsten Cinema is up in 2024
and the fact that she is no longer a
Democrat could of course mean that now
Democrats could hold a primary and have
a candidate who runs against Cinema you
could end up with a Democrat a
Republican and independent Kirsten
Cinema in Arizona that would change the
Dynamics of that race but we're going to
table that for the time being here's my
my primary thought about this and we're
going to hear from Bernie Sanders in a
moment about this my primary thought
is that this does seem motivated by a
desire for attention
particularly with the win by Raphael
Warnock it seems as though the question
now is well is it 5149 or is it 50 50
and the question really has to do with
caucusing Angus King and Bernie Sanders
are not Democrats but they caucus with
Democrats and that's where we got for
the last two years it's 50 50 rather
than 48 50 and 2. let's listen to what
Kirsten Cinema had to say she was
interviewed by Jake Tapper about this
powerful decision that she made you're
here to make a significant announcement
I've registered as an Arizona
independent I know some people might be
a little bit surprised by this but
actually I think it makes a lot of sense
we're not that surprised Kirsten you
know a growing member of arizonans and
people like me just don't feel like we
fit neatly into one party's box or the
other and so like many across the state
and the nation I've decided to leave
that partisan process and really just
focus on the work that I think matters
to Arizona into our country which is
solving problems and getting things done
now understand that
being in the being in the Senate and
being a Democrat and then saying I'm
leaving the Democratic party because I
no longer fit into that box now I'm
outside of partisanship this is one of
the silliest things I mean we've talked
about this before it's sort of like
people who say
I don't vote because I I think all of
these excuse me Republican politicians
and Democratic politicians none of them
have our best interests in mind so I'm
above and outside of the partisan Fray
by never voting for any of these losers
that's a very political decision it's
still political and I would argue it is
still partisan because you're basically
saying I don't see an appreciable
difference between Democrats and
Republicans even though there are so
many differences that I'm saying they're
equally bad and I'm voting for that's a
very partisan and political statement so
this is starting to get into the kind of
enlightened centrism that we've been
critical of let's listen to the rest of
her statement here so
your voting record is pretty capital D
Democratic I mean your views are
generally that of a moderate Centrist
Democrat how does leaving the party
change how you do your job well I don't
think anything will change about how I
do my job
arizonans sent me to the United States
Senate to be an independent voice for
our state and I'll continue doing that
That's a classic by the way oh I was
sent here to be an independent voice to
think for myself all right but now it is
interesting I will mention that there is
footage of Kirsten Cinema
chastising Joe Lieberman for doing the
exact same thing going from the
Democratic party to Independence she now
she's doing it and now it's great now
it's a sign of virtue but in the past
she was critical of Joe Lieberman for
doing exactly that I've been negotiated
with the Senate so what does that mean
well in the Senate we no longer have 60
votes some would argue that we never had
60 because one of those was Joseph
liberated right but that's oh whatever
um
so so now there's um I think as a
president so eloquently said on
Wednesday there's none of this pressure
this false pressure to get to 60. so
what that means is that um the Democrats
um can stop
um kowtowing to Joe Lieberman and
instead seek other avenues
isn't that interesting the way that
they've had to cow Tao or will have to
cow Tao to Kirsten Cinema and Joe
manchin so the hypocrisy
adds to my feeling that this is a plea
for attention and she's getting the
attention and here I am covering it as
well because it is relevant we will have
to see if and how this changes Cinema's
voting let's now talk about the reaction
from Bernie Sanders
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below